вітаємо це програма Європа У фокусі я
Лари бабалола Ласкаво просимо протягом
століть саме вода допомагала захищати
крихітний архіпелаг Венеції від
загарбників але тепер вода сама стала
загрозою у 2019 році це італійське місто
пережило найсильнішу за останні
десятиліття повінь коли лагуну затопило
під час припливу
води постраждали історичні будівлі та
архітектурні шедеври менші повені
продовжують вражати Венецію оскільки
рівень моря підвищується а фундамент
міста
просідає але цього року ситуація може
змінитися на користь венет проект мози
систему мобільних шлюзів що слугують
бар'єром між морем і лагуною нарешті
завершено коли приплив занадто високий
мозие активується щоб зупинити прорив
води в місто Але збереження Венеції
сухої обходиться не дешево морський
дослідник Георг умгісер попереджає що
шлюзи - це лише короткострокове Рі
Венеція зачаровує світ Уже понад 1600
років і так само довго люди боялися
пованей або переживали що місто може
піти під
воду це найновіша спроба захистити
Венецію 78 металевих бар'єрів які можна
підняти щоб відокремити море від Лагуни
система називається
мозе якби у нас не було мозенеція Знала
б непоправних руйнувань 22 листопада
2022 року це була друга за величиною
повінь в історії але нічого не сталося
ми змогли захистити лагуну і
Венецію Елізабета шпіц уже віддавала
наказ підняти бар'єри понад 50
разів і їй доводиться робити це все
частіше
тепер ми знаємо що мози - це гнучкий
інструмент який не завжди потрібно
піднімати і не завжди
одночасно Сьогодні ми знаємо набагато
більше про повені та вітер тому можемо
протидіяти повеням використовувати
систему моза лише частково і гарантувати
обмін водою між морем і лагуною
[музика]
що означає це що Венеція може бути
врятована експерти з клімату прогнозують
Що рівень моря може піднятися на 60 см
до кінця
століття океанолог Георг умгісер каже що
мозе просто виграє час
чи достатньо мозе щоб врятувати
Венецію так На даний момент безумовно
найближчі 102 чи 30 років але якщо
рівень моря підніметься на 50 см її
доведеться використовувати 300-400 разів
тобто раз на день вона не впорається
моза не зможе впоратися як споруда але й
Лагуна не впорається тому що їй потрібен
обмін
води Марко сіговіні з венеціанського
інституту морських наук досліджує
екосистему Лагуни Він каже що частота з
якою використовуються мози поки що не
мала жодних серйозних наслідків але це
може змінитися якщо лагуну
від'єднуватимуть від моря частіше і на
довший
час
Можливо в якийсь момент Нам доведеться
вирішити чи є сенс підтримувати лагуну
як солону водойму чи ні тривале
перекриття Лагуни перериває цикл між
морем і лагуною що має фундаментальне
значення для
Венеції саме це формує дно Лагуни що
визначає які рослини і тварини можуть
там жити нам доведеться приймати
непрості
рішення врятувати
лагуну чи
[музика]
місто венеціанці ви далі хотіли б
зберегти і те і інше площа санмарко
найнижча точка Венеції яка затоплюється
першою зараз ведуться роботи щоб підняти
площу якщо її підняти на 110 см то площа
більше не буде під водою тому що до 110
см вона буде витримувати без затоплення
А при перевищенні система мози
закриється іншими словами на площі Сан
Марко більше не було б
затоплень він вважає що нам потрібно
мати Віру люди часто забувають що
Венеція опустилася на 30 см за останні
150 років занадто багато підземних вод
було викачено з міських водоносних
горизонтів але підземні води також
можуть допомогти врятувати місто від
катастрофи якщо викачену воду закачати
назад то Венеція може знову піднятися на
см це будуть саме ті 30 см які ми
втратили за останні 150
років Тобто ми повернемося назад Так би
мовити почнемо з
нуля Він каже що Венеція якою ми її
знаємо в будь-якому випадку не може
тривати вічно у якийсь момент лагуну
доведеться відокремити від
моря і венеціанці будуть змушені
прийняти це рішення
і те інше не можна врятувати Треба
вирішити що саме треба рятувати і саме
Венецію бо Венеція тільки
одна складне рішення венеційці
сподіваються що їм ніколи не доведеться
його Приймати
це терапія яка може стати переломним
моментом у боротьбі з раком радіоізотопи
можуть не лише виявляти а й націлюватись
на ракові клітини та знищувати їх проте
лише декілька ядерних дослідницьких
реакторів у світі можуть їх виробляти А
зі старінням цієї інфраструктури та
зростанням рівня захворюваності на рак у
світі попит на них швидко випереджає
пропозицію Більшість таких дослідницьких
реакторів знаходиться в Європі серед них
один у Бельгії вчені там кажуть якщо ЄС
хоче уникнути серйозного дефіциту
потрібно будувати більше об'єктів і
швидко для багатьох місцевих мешканців
це моторошне видовище купол ядерного
реактора це станція в місті моль Бельгія
одна із найстаріших у Європі однак
насправді вона використовується не для
виробництва енергії а для наукових
досліджень вона відіграє центральну роль
у ядерній медицині Бернар понсар виріс
так би мовити разом із br2 і пишається
його
історією це безумовно один з
найважливіших реакторів для надійного
постачання медичних радіоізотопів у
всьому
світі
молів Ден 99 або скорочено Молі 99 - це
назва такого жаданого ізотипу який дає
змогу на точно діагностувати Рак та
метастази для 40 мільйонів пацієнтів у
всьому Світі але як і всі радіоактивні
ізотопи він
нестабільний через 66 годин половина
активності продукту
зникає Ми не можемо робити запаси тому
що дуже важливо щоб у нас була дуже
хороша координація Між тими двома а
насправді шістьма реакторами які задіяні
в глобальному постачанні Молі
99 але в Німеччині вже виникли певні
вузькі місця і лікування було відкладено
Тому що у світі є лише шість реакторів
які виробляють цей
Ізотоп чотири в Європі у Бельгії
Нідерландах Польщі та Чехії один в
Австралії і один у Південній
Африці в Америці та Азії жодного
50% світового виробництва Молі 99
спрямовується до Сполучених Штатів
Америки і
Канади тож Північна Америка основний
споживач Молі
99 Європа споживає 25% світового попиту
а 25% постачається порешті
світу США Утім постачають урани пильно
стежать за безпекою старі бельгійського
реактора моль - це також дослідницький
центр який займається розробкою ліків
майбутнього
радіо ізотопи використовуються не лише
для діагностики раку але і для його
лікування радіоактивність і зпоміж
усього іншого може зрештою змінити
правила
гри Зараз проводиться Багато клінічних
випробувань багато дослідницьких груп
намагаються впровадити нові сполуки у
клініки тож я думаю що ми ми бачимо лише
верхівку
айсберга завдяки правильній комбінації
молекули носія та ізотопу ракові клітини
можна прицільно вражати не зачіпаючи
здорові тканини із набагато меншою
кількістю побічних
ефектів Таким чином можна атакувати
навіть дуже агресивні види
раку ядерна медицина переживає бум новий
інститут Жюля борде - це найкраща
лікарня у Бельгії для лікування раку тут
радіо і зотопи використовуються для
діагностики але також застосовуються для
лікування раку передміхурової залози на
пізніх стадіях що навіть робить
пацієнтів радіоактивними на добу після
ін'єкції радіоізотопу пацієнт повинен
бути ізольований протягом 24
годин за словами професора Патріка
фламена Після чотирьох ін'єкцій хлини
зменшилися Щонайменше у третини
пацієнтів які не реагували на інші
методи лікування це ще не лікування але
це продовжує життя і полегшує біль успіх
можна побачити на так званому
пецскануванні Це камера вартістю 2
мільни євро яка робить видимою роботу
радіоактивних частинок в організмі на
тлі сонячного неба і бельгійського
узбережжя така обстановка забирає
частину тривоги яку відчувають пацієнти
коли заходять у Цю кімнату адже це один
із найбільш стресових моментів які можна
собі уявити у житті
пацієнта адже саме ця техніка визначає
чи ефективне їхніліку
[музика]
можливості які пропонує ядерна медицина
збільшили попит на ізотопи А разом із
цим і навантаження на реактори яких дуже
мало ЄС хоче виділити мільйони на
фінансування таких досліджень але
реактори не будуються за одну ніч і у
багатьох людей Вони викликають страх
зруйновані могили на кладовищі ділянки
поглинуті землею руйнування спричинені
не землетрусом а прова
жителі південного польського міста
чебіння стурбовані величезними кратерами
які почали з'являтися два роки тому у
корені цієї проблеми шахта яка була
виведена із експлуатації кілька
десятиліть тому женовефа ковачак
нещодавно овдовіла і оплакує смерть
свого чоловіка але вона не може
відвідати його могилу воронка зробила
частину кладовища недоступною для
відвідування мешканці чебіньї живуть у
страху не знаючи чи не провалиться земля
під
ними
[оплески]
воронки були настільки великими Що
обвалювалися цілі
будівлі люди бояться за своє
життя тут багато
будинків якщо такий будинок провалиться
хтось точно
загине ніхто не знає де ще небезпечно
чебінья невелике місто на півдні Польщі
розташоване над величезною порожниною
яку залишила по собі вуглевидобувна
промисловість і воно поступово
обвалюється наприклад ось гігантська
воронка яку поспіхом
засипали Ян Маєвський живе за декілька
будинків звідси на вулиці Івана Павла і
він живе з дружи но заради якого вони
переїхали в село чоловік дуже
стурбований він ніби намагається
стримувати непереборну
силу я тількино підсипав сюди землю тут
все було
рівно А тепер видно що знову
просіло мені справді
[музика]
страшно лягаю спати і не знаю чи не
провалиться земля під нами наступного
ранку опиниться вона ще на метр
глибше вугільну шахту у чебіньї закрили
на зламі тисячоліть і відтоді підземні
шахти заповнилися водою і розм'якшили
землю вона почала
просідати це кладовище постраждало
влітку десятки могил зникли у воронці це
було сильним шоком для жиновевки ковачак
її родинну могилу врятували але вона
більше не може відвідувати могилу свого
чоловіка он там де жовтий кран білий
надгробок
позаду половина цвинтеря закрита через
побоювання нових провалів це важко Мій
чоловік помер зовсім
нещодавно усе що в неї залишилося це
фото на телефоні і надія що цвинтар
Незабаром буде відновлено
міська Влада чебінії перебуває у
надзвичайному стані дехто вже говорить
про евакуацію на мера Ярослава окочука
тиснуть щоб він вжив
заходів
спмин ми розплачуємося за помилки
минулого помилки допущені в період
підземного видобутку вугілля коли шахти
були в
експлуатації наслідки були забуті а
коли я дивлюся на всі ці документи
Сьогодні я вважаю що це можна було б
передбачити низку об'єктів у місті
оточено парканом людей туди не
пускають державна компанія
спеціалізується на ліквідації наслідків
замінування вони бурять свертловини на
70 м у глиб землі геологи впевнені що
їхній метод допоможе запобігти утворенню
провалів у
[музика]
майбутньому ми заповнимо ці порожнини
суміщу пилу цементу та піску щоб
унеможливити просідання Землі в
майбутньому труби подібні до цих були
вкопані в землю повсюди в чебіньї і
тисячі кубометрів цементу було залито
щоб заповнити порожнечі мер сподівається
що це допоможе Він вважає що це
обов'язок Польської
держави я не маю наміру використовувати
ресурси міста для вирішення проблеми на
яку ми не мали жодного
впливу і від наслідків якої на жаль
страждаємо
зараз повертаємося на вулицю Івана Павла
і ян Маєвський відвідує свого сусіда
войцеха крамаржа який нещодавно виявив
тріщини у стінах свого невеликого амбару
ця будівля старша за нього але тріщини
з'явилися зовсім нещодавно тонни цементу
вже закачали в землю на його ділянці Але
чоловік сумнівається що це допоможе він
каже робітники пішли далі раніше ніж
дірки були повністю
заповнені з тим як вони тут працюють Ви
не впевнені Чи все зроблено на 100%
правильно чи проблема повернеться
знову через кілька днів Земля у його
районі знову провалилася на волосок від
багатоквартирного будинку
мешканці чибіньї продовжують жити в
страху єгиптяни будували піраміди як
пам'ятники фараонам і у столиці Албанії
також є одна із них початково побудована
на честь покійного диктатора за часів
комуністичного правління тиранська
піраміда була музеєм присвяченим
колишньому лідеру енверу ходжі згодом
вона отримала нове життя як пам'ятник
народу Зараз цю піраміду перетворили на
культурний центр Але не всі від цього у
захваті
фатос лубоні був ув'язнений за часів
комуністичного диктаторського режиму Він
вважає нещодавно відреставровану
піраміду пробую висвітлити темну
сторінку в історії своєї
країни Вона має все необхідне щоб стати
новою визначною пам'яткою столиці
Албанії
ни піраміда у самому серці міста щодня
сотні місцевих жителів і туристів
піднімаються на неї щоб помилуватися
краєвидом із її
верхівки як тут гарно Зазвичай я не дуже
добре долаю вершини але тут мені це
вдалося було би чудово якби тут був ліфт
для нас літніх
людей як тут все змінилося я ще пам'ятаю
як це виглядало раніше а зараз дуже
гарно тому щоця піраміда вже була
визначною пам'яткою трани колись 35
років
тому вона була відкрита як музей енвера
ходжі і присвячена колишньому диктатору
Албанії
ходжа був сталіністом чиє жорстоке
правління тривало понад 40 років
фатос лубонія був одним із десятків
тисяч політичних в'язнів тих часів Він
каже що оця піраміда була символом
репресій А зараз стала символом
історичного невігластва су
[музика]
Албанії подивіться на цей гарний
Бельведер ви піднімаєтеся і бачите
тирану з нього але тут вже не залишилося
того лайна яке йшло від цієї піраміди і
під лайном Я маю на увазі символіку
диктатури вдома лубонья показує нам що
він мав на увазі батько лубоньї був
посадовцем режиму ходжі Доки не потрапив
у немилість уся сім'я була змушена
спокутувати провину на чотирх осіб
звинуватили в агітації пропаганді проти
режиму зарештували і всю сім'ю
відправили в заслання
лубонья був в'язним режиму ходжі
протягом 17 років більшу частину цього
часу він провів на примусових роботах у
сумнозвісній в'язниці
спач Це залишки світильника
лампи Ми використовували їх у
шахті
спач був схожий на сталінський гулах
пекло на землі виживання у нелюдських
умовах майже всі книги були суворо
заборонені окрім словників які лубоні
використовував щоб сховати те що згодом
зробить його
відомим свою першу книгу написано на
цигарковому папері під час ув'язнення
мініатюрним
почерком
зараз лубоньє письменник і художник а
також критик в
Албанії На його думку відреставрована
піраміда - це спроба стерти темну
історію комунізму в Албанії
Ніхто з молодого покоління не може
прийти сюди і знайти сліди
минулого зовсім навпаки каже архітектор
генті
аголі плануючи нову піраміду
відповідальні голландські архітектори
завжди дбали про те щоб зробити минуле
видимим найважливішу зміну можна знайти
на
сходах люди повинні відчувати що вони
підкорюють
піраміду символічно виступають проти
комунізму і
диктатури знову і знову історія цієї
споруди розкривається у різних її
куточках
це стара частина і вона лише пофарбована
і то грубо щоб показати історію цієї
будівлі у новій піраміді все обертається
навколо майбутнього у різнокольорових
кубах вбудованих у величезний простір
розмістився центр креативних технологій
тумо тут молодь може навчитися
реалізовувати свої ідеї за допомогою
найсучасніших технологій долучитися може
будь-хто І це
безкоштовно йшла кілька ознайомчих
курсів у тумо і думаю що буду
продовжувати Я бачу своє майбутнє у
галузі технологій викладачі також
простягають руку допомоги у майстерні по
сусідству наближається до завершення
один проєкт і він не про комп'ютерні
ігри а про темне минуле Албанії
це клас графічного дизайну в
тумо і ми працюємо над проектом про
в'язницю
спач
проект про в'язницю в якій утримувався
фатос лубонья можливо албанська Молодь
не настільки безпам'ятна до історії як
він
боїться важливо зрозуміти як це
було як це зло було створено і як ми так
постраждали від цього зла ну як так
могло статися я вважаю що це не має
повторитися здається саме над цим і
працюють у новій
[музика]
піраміді доставка на вимогу здійснила
революцію світі споживання але ця
вантажівка у Франції не схожа на жодну
іншу одним натисканням кнопки вона
перетворюється на Кінотеатр це культура
за запитом для маленьких містечок де
немає кінотеатрів ініціатива підтримана
державою замість того щоб дивитися
фільми вдома глядачі різного віку
збираються разом аби отримати унікальний
кінематографічний досвід
що ж усе безумовно покращилося із часів
мобільних бібліотек у моєму дитинстві і
на цьому Ми завершуємо цьоготижневий
випуск Європа У фокусі Дякуємо що були з
нами і до зустрічі наступного
тижня
[музика]